oh here's you dude i was just about to
say you look like him
damn that's what i looked like
hey brandon hey theo what do you think
of bears [ __ ]
your backyard it's your own national
geographic [ __ ] gang gang bear [ __ ]
oh he has two black beards doing
black sand and look at that oh what a
cool backyard yeah that's a gift
and if you see a black animal do you
relate differently to a black animal
since you have a darker skin
yeah i kind of root for them yeah i feel
that
yeah it's like family feud when they're
like
it's my family it's like family you
always side with one family
i always do you want a great reference
you always do
man yeah damn the gift of black bears in
your backyard
man and doing sex too man my buddy's dog
used to do sex with every dog and we
would take it down to the park and just
watch it just
that sounds like a nice day oh we'd be
down there old ones yeah people would
come in with their dogs thinking that he
wasn't going to try to bang it in this
dog would go
right pink rocket comes out every time
man
i mean oh we're about to see it
apollo skirt teen dude
this thing was hunting leg dog
the dog's just watching it oh yeah yeah
oh yeah your dog is a freak
that dog is a freak i love how you got
just got in position
yeah yeah trying to look up [ __ ]
right there
he's like oh i just had a shower
he just cleaned me that dog is trying to
look dang delectable bro
[Laughter]
what else you got nick what do you want
to see what do you want relationship
advice yeah what do you want us to do
nick
oh yeah we would love some more
relationship advices
uh send in videos of your aunt if you do
flop my aunt
uh videos of your clown my hounds we
have a couple of clown my hounds but
yeah
always send in videos not just images
we're not going to read
what you say i'll tell you what i can't
stop listening to that little brows
[ __ ]
king the sting rap he did that [ __ ] was
f would you just post it that was hot
on that what's popping he floated he
floated yeah
yeah he floated he floated yeah he's a
real animal
[Music]
is